-This is very exciting.
I love this show.
This is a David Simon show.
-Yeah, it is.
-You were in "The Wire,"
another David Simon show,
and you were fantastic in both.
Fantastic in that,
you´re fantastic in this.
You have a theory that rappers
make great actors for a reason.
-Yeah,
because we´re great liars.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Period.
-All rappers are liars.
-With a straight face, too.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Absolutely.
The best liars.
-And what --
Where does the lying come from?
Is it essential
to being a good rapper?
-You know, I think it´s people
building themselves up
to a point where,
you know, they´re gods.
-Uh-huh.
-As a matter of fact,
I remember Kanye West saying,
"I told you who I was."
-Yeah.
-"I´m a god!"
-Right.
-And that´s exactly what it was.
-So, wait. Are you telling me
he might not actually be a god?
-No, Kanye´s a god.
-Kanye is a god. Okay.
So that´s not lying.
That´s the straight truth.
-Straight truth.
-And you have
a very unique haircut
in this show, as we can see.
-Ah, yeah.
-Inspired by?
-Reverend Al Sharpton!
Big up to Reverend Al.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes, sir.
- So you are --
You are playing a pimp
in the New York in the ´70s.
And was this your idea?
Did you say,
"I want an Al Sharpton look?"
-Um, Kind of.
-Yeah.
Well, you know,
I didn´t actually
use the Al Sharpton reference,
but it was kind of in that vein.
I really wanted
Ron O´Neal, "Super Fly,"
but, you know, I needed somebody
East Coast-based,
and Al Sharpton was the greatest
target I could use right there.
-Oh, that´s fantastic.
And, obviously,
you live in New York.
You´re from Staten Island.
-Yeah.
-You grew up --
Did you -- Did you experience
that Times Square at all
when you were young?
-Me and my dad, yeah.
He would take me there on Easter
to Times Square.
I mean --
-So that doesn´t seem like
where you would take a child
on Easter.
-You know what?
You´re right.
But the way I remember it,
I just remember
the bright lights, the big city,
the movie theater, how it
actually looked like a theater,
where you could do
a play or something at.
It was like, for a young guy,
a young kid,
we didn´t see
the underbelly of it.
We just saw
the glamour and the glitz.
And that was the point.
-That´s interesting,
because I think, the first time
I came here, I wouldn´t have --
I didn´t notice
the seediness at all, either.
You were so taken by the fact
that it was New York City.
-Right.
-When you say movie theaters --
So what were the things
that you that your dad
would take you to see?
Would you guys --
-Bruce Lee.
-Okay.
-Bruce Lee movies.
I´m a big Bruce fan.
Everybody that knows me
knows I love Bruce.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I remember
"Godzilla vs. Megalon."
-Uh-huh.
-Come on!
Godzilla fans in here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That´s what I´m saying.
-And was your --
was your dad going
because he knew you liked it,
or did he also like it?
-I believe he liked it,
but I think it was
more of a show-off thing,
because we both had on, like,
these denim one-piece suits.
-Uh-huh.
-Really tacky.
-Really tacky?
And I don´t know
where he found one in my size,
but we were twins that day.
-That´s great.
That´s really fun.
It´s Easter, let´s get in our
denim and go see "Godzilla."
-Go see "Godzilla."
[ Laughter ]
-Just as the Bible tells you.
[ Laughing ]
So, this is the other
great thing about New York.
And someone like you,
you´re obviously
part of this New York social
scene, New York celebrity.
And we´ve had so many people
on this show since the election
that have admitted they crossed
paths with Donald Trump.
-Yeah.
-He was just here.
He was everywhere.
You actually got Donald Trump to
record something for your album.
-Yes, yes.
Thanks to Russell Simmons.
Russell is a friend of his,
and Russell called in a favor.
´Cause I just wanted a bunch of
different cameos on my album,
saying, you know,
where is this album at.
´Cause it had really been
four years
since I dropped my first album.
-Yeah.
-So, you know,
and Donald Trump dialed in
and did Russell a favor.
And, you know, him and Russell
are really tight.
Then, I think Russell said,
"I rebuke you, Satan,"
and that was the end of it.
-Yeah.
-But this is -- this is --
If you were listening
to a Method Man album,
you would actually hear this
on one of the tracks.
-Hey, Method Man,
this is Donald Trump,
and I´m in Palm Beach,
and we´re all waiting
for your album.
Let´s get going, man.
Everybody´s waiting
for this album.
-He´s even lying there.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that´s -- much like
a rapper, he´s a liar.
-He´s a liar.
He´s a liar.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-But you --
There was --
I do think there´s
something to be said about
there is a similarity, I think,
with Trump and rap,
and there was something
about his style
that you were drawn to.
-Which style is that?
-Well, just, like, excess.
-Oh, he doesn´t give a [bleep]
And he doesn´t give a [bleep]
Yeah.
Pretty much.
And that is a credo in hip-hop,
not to give a [bleep]
-If he --
If he could rhyme,
I think he´d have
an excellent rap career.
-He doesn´t have the voice.
His voice is annoying.
I think Melania would have
a better career than him.
-Melania, yeah.
-Yes.
Yes,
you know we love white women.
-Yeah, that´s true.
-Come on.
-Melania, at the very least,
could stand in the back
in fatigues,
just like one of those things.
-Pretty much.
-Yeah.
-She´s cute.
I can´t even front.
Melania´s a very cute lady.
-Yeah, mm-hmm.